i got a quality out there from this dude
named steve chavoni just out of the blue
yeah we talk once a year whenever i go
to buffalo because that's when we talk
two days before i land
he comes to the hotel we eat lunch we
smoke a joint we hug because he's one of
the oldest friends i have in the world
from life that was crazy yeah like he
knew me when i was the real deal weapons
we were friends for about
from 83 to 87
and then he met
claudine jean-jane's daughter the chick
that killed her uh her husband and aspen
doug this is [ __ ] this is one of the
murders one of those celebrity murders
in aspen
she was a hot-looking chick and he was a
hot skier
so anyway me and steve chavoni became
friends at the in-n-out house
in 1983 because they made original east
coast [ __ ] yeah the only thing they did
was add sprouts the first time i've been
to one of their sandwiches
and i tasted sprouts
i almost killed the [ __ ] you
understand me i was like what the [ __ ]
is this
promise i think i'm off for you lisa
yeah you know me
i don't lie about food
it was the only place where i had the
curry chicken and rye bread
with [ __ ] lettuce tomato it was
sensational yeah these guys were from
buffalo he had a
he had a [ __ ] owner named amir who
was bald-headed
kind of a nice guy but he was a [ __ ]
scumbag the face of that restaurant was
steve chavoni and it was the size of
this joint yeah
and i became friends with steve in 83
and i disappeared i went back to new
york and [ __ ] up and moved into a
rocket ship at a park i was homeless
then i went i ended up back in aspen and
i'm living in the whole town
across the street from the end of that
house so i'm going over there and i'm
eating on the yard
yeah
put it on the arm and they like me that
i'm in there i'm the real deal it's
1984. i got a real new york accent it's
85. yeah
and i'm living across the street from
the hotel in those days bro this is the
type of [ __ ] i was
like when i got bored that meant i was
trying to rob something
so i'd be sitting there watching tv and
i go tick-tock you know i'm sitting here
watching the football games there's
something out there that needs to be
rubbed
like that that's how [ __ ] up i was
yeah that's how [ __ ] up i was and i'm
not scared to admit this i would see
businesses in the daytime like oh i
could rub this joint
this joint don't have an arm i kick this
door down take this painting i always
had a scam when i was walking and make
mental notes in those days it's like joe
rogan said he goes the first time i went
to bowl and i looked around i was like i
can't picture you in 85. it's like a
candy store yeah so your candy store i
could pick this [ __ ] off like nothing i
came from new york city where everything
is bolted they bought you the bedroom in
the back rooms go to a new york bathroom
they lock in from the outside
they bought everything in new york yeah
the place in aspen
so one night i bought the pieces and i
go how can i break into the sandwich
place
where the little place is i've been
feeding you the guy who's been feeding
me that's how bored
because i knew they made cash yeah i
knew he only made deposits once a week
like fridays they did two three grand a
day yeah they're making a deposit a day
with in your
tummy it might tell that yeah i was
still painful
yeah and are you eating around the arm
this is how crazy it was guys this is
not crazy oh my god there's only one way
in there yeah there was i could go
through the front door kick it i like
clint eastwood but the cops drive by
it's off season
it was the beginning of the season or
i could kick the window on top you know
like the window that flips yeah and in
those days i was 185 i was pretty built
i couldn't fit through a thing i said
how am i gonna bust this riddle
right and i said let me do something i
went on top of the roof of the hotel
which was three stories but i could see
the roof and guess what they had like a
a little duct to take off oh yeah
and i went around the back and voila
what's behind the back a [ __ ] ladder
that goes right up that starts over here
i went up there i picked the [ __ ]
thing and i leap down there like
spiderman yeah like my shoulder i still
probably have a scar
i cut like my shoulder but nothing the
adrenaline kicks up when you're a
burglar and sure enough i went in there
and i was correct that was [ __ ]
eighteen hundred dollars or something
and i made like i know i'm not gonna
tell you i made a sandwich i took like a
piece of bread
and i walked out the front door like i
owned the joint yeah the next day
when i went in there like i wasn't there
like nothing a few pieces of meat maybe
like i was in there like nothing i mean
and guess what i went around the top
right i went back i emptied my pockets
yeah i went back out on the roof
and screwed everything down again like
nothing happens so that's a gentleman
you know what i mean
you gotta yeah
i'm gonna rob them and leave the latch
open yeah the next day i wanted to get a
sandwich and they're all looking at me
weird
but steve schiavone and i still became
friends with you note this
is going to hear this and go you know
like oh yeah okay we were doing blow one
night he got a dog called kali a half
wolf dog yeah and i had a german
shepherd called hercules
and they used to play with each other
and i was house sitting and on friday
nights i would have little cocaine
parties and one night we got coked up
and he goes dog did you rob that [ __ ]
sandwich place and i go come on you know
i did
when i went in there and i saw that box
yeah you're the first person i thought
he goes until this day we really the
owner really can't blame you
because how the [ __ ] did you get in
there what he goes i'm going to lose my
he goes i almost lost my job because i
thought i gave you the key oh he goes
the next day we went in there and the
door was open
how did you get in right yeah yeah they
didn't even know that i jumped down
there like spiderman that's when i found
that's when i found the [ __ ] way in
those days
that's how i used to find the [ __ ]
way it was crazy yeah
that's a crazy [ __ ] story
anyway this podcast
is brought to you
by me undies listen to me there's a new
there's a reason i've been telling you
about me undies for months now they're
simply the softest most comfortable
underwear
you'll ever
have on once you try them you won't want
to wear anything else trust me what i'm
telling you if you go to my house my
underwear drawer all you see is a color
of different me undies and right now i'm
going to get you 20 off your first pair
plus free shipping at meundies.com
joey right now that's meundies.com
joey this show is also brought to you by
quip here's something to chew on many
recent studies suggest that having good
oral health impacts your overall health
yet most of us do not brush our teeth
properly you can start brushing better
today with quip the new company that's
refreshing people the way
refreshing the way people brush their
teeth
whip is an electronic toothbrush that
packs premium vibration and a timer
feature into an ultimate slim design
right now go to quick.com joey to get
your first refill pack free with equip
electric toothbrush that's your first
refill pack free at
joey go to quip
g-e-t-q-u-i-p
dot-com slash joey and get your first
refill pack free number three let me
explain something to you father's day is
over with mother's day is over with and
you're still walking around with a
filthy [ __ ] [ __ ] let me tell you
something
it's june
26th if your [ __ ] is stinking up a
storm now can you imagine during bikini
season when that [ __ ] muffler is
overheating with humidity that [ __ ]
stopped today go to hellotushy.com you
know why because the bidet is back [ __ ]
no longer do you have to walk around
with swamp ass if your monkeys got wang
to it if your nut sack has a little
[ __ ]
you don't need that in your life no more
it's summertime keep that muffler
refreshed and keep those balls and
monkey refreshed go to hellotushy.com
right now and get 10 off when you go to
hellotuture.com church there you go
right now that's who presents this
church to you coming at you kick that
mule lee
i only play this type of music when one
guest is in the house
his name is steve burns
direct from pittsburgh we ain't [ __ ]
around here you understand man
he grew up on the mean streets of
pittsburgh
he ain't one of you [ __ ] okie doke
[ __ ]
looking at the floor when you tell me
you're gonna do something your [ __ ]
nuts
you can learn something from steve burns
it's tuesday september 27th
it's the luckiest day of your [ __ ]
life [ __ ] listen to shafts listen
to the guitar
there's one black people with black
people listen to this [ __ ]
these people wouldn't even be invited to
bp awards
anyways the church what's happening now
cop sucker
june 26 the day the devil was buried at
sea [ __ ] in the ass
gang raped and etc etc
steve burn in the house who is the man
who [ __ ] you up with his little [ __ ]
hand
[Music]
it's sad to believe that isaac hayes
became a scientologist after he wrote
this he got scared
you know that [ __ ] nah that's why he got
that pistachio commercial three years
ago you're sitting there going look keep
that keep that alive keep this black
keep that soul alive because it kicks in
it kicks in but isn't that why isn't
that why he left south park not because
of it but it was because of his beliefs
yeah he just had his own south park
good to see you my brother always good
just read your [ __ ] i love you
twitter and i laughed my ass off
your little poses there's a black people
black people here we go
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i want to go solve a crime
i want to go committed i want to commit
a crime that's what this music makes you
do kill this kill this mural it's so
funny good to see you bro it's a choice
this reminds me of being maybe 10
when this came out this is one of those
movies that black people went crazy and
i wasn't part of the movement
like i was there i was a kid and i saw
the impact
and i finally like you weren't cool till
you went to see this chef yeah when i
was growing up there was no standing
online for apple
you know marvel movies no if you went to
those you got beat up
[Laughter]
the the plan was to come back and brag
to your 10 year olds that you went to
see an r rated movie
yeah and people would flip out like
how'd you do it what movie do you cause
then you would find out there was always
one chick that didn't ask you yeah like
i went to see the exorcist the longest
yard
and to the dragon what the same movie
thing like i saw academy of woodward is
it tommy
it could be an r-rated movie or it could
be a pg movie she never asked me for it
oh that's great but i still remember
going to the exorcist
and the line
to go to the exorcism when i don't have
letting kids in it's really scary
and i went in there and she's like go
right ahead and i was like oh [ __ ]
did you look older though no i was
telling you no yeah
where was the theater was it in like
48th street in bergen line avenue wait
what every time i drive by and i beat
the [ __ ] hornet is it nice or kind of
like more
blue collar
it was blue collar in those days okay it
was the movie theater it was 20 blocks
from my mother's bar okay my mother
would let me walk there
and
i'm telling you tommy the longest yard
french connection
anything violent like that i could go
back to catholic school on monday
barbarella
i don't remember going to see barbarella
but i still remember going along iraqi
rocky i still remember seeing the
longest yard there yeah
and the movie theater was on their feet
yelling and then what was it like to
actually that's why i mean that's crazy
right
when i got this
the whole first two weeks all i thought
about was me being a kid and walking out
of there with john bender yeah you know
dominic speciale and walking home and we
were the mean machine yeah that was it
that football season we were going to be
the mean machine when we played flag
football and
that was it you know what i'm saying
yeah
it's [ __ ] weird enter the dragon i
probably went to see it there
every night while he was there i still
remember enter the dragon coming out
and like a couple days later he's dead
and people were like yeah
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
because there was no internet then yeah
so only chinese people knew the news
that hit chinatown and then it spread
outward yeah and by the time i got i was
three weeks late to the party i was
heartbroken
i found that yeah i found out like a
week after he died yeah and i couldn't
believe it but then that's how removed
you were from the asian community yeah
well no in those days i went to
chinatown every saturday yeah like we
all saved up money to go to chinatown
yeah we go to chinatown we'd buy that
leather meat
we thought it was cool we'd buy the
ointment to put on our hands to practice
the iron palm technique yeah because we
would watch it in the movies and [ __ ]
we'd get a bag see lisey the canvas bag
and fill it up with like chickpeas and
pellets
and every day like three of us would get
together in the afternoon
by the little fire we burn our hands
through the [ __ ]
so you're not exactly going for your
love of the chinese culture yeah
we do all that crap
no re for that this is all [ __ ] just
being possible
right yeah yeah you know it's funny when
i see tributes to bruce lee and i don't
see a 40 year old like i don't see
nobody who even remembered the impact
yeah and the disappointment like the
impact of bruce lee by 1971
by 1972
you [ __ ] knew who bruce lee was if
you were a kid like he had yeah he had
[ __ ] up j he trumped james bond he
trumped everybody at that time that's
why enter the dragon is james bond yeah
they send them to an island and he meets
the chick and it's james bond yeah they
he he trump james bond like he he had
[ __ ] up denise wood charles bronson
was taking it back like this chinese
[ __ ] dude this can't be yeah he
[ __ ] up the whole market kung fu
schools
everybody started dressing chinese yeah
everybody bought the [ __ ] shirts with
the white shirt underneath that you have
to roll up the sleeves and then you put
the black over that with the thing
everybody bought the shoes including me
my mom even thought of taking me to a
psychiatrist i said i said i would eat
rice i would burn incense in my room i
would bow i was [ __ ] losing my mind
you're good at math i was good at math
studying the violin the whole [ __ ]
thing
karate breathing
every night i get together with mario
diaz who was a cuban chinese guy
and these other two dudes glenn colon
and this other dude after dinner it was
well known that after you went to your
training yep and you went home and ate
dinner with your family and then did
your homework
if you could talk to your mama how to
leave him for a half hour at nine
o'clock
we would have a ghee over there for you
and we would train
oh yeah
and bro it was like a for a year every
night we would go there and no kicking
to the head yeah body allowed no balls
uh if you want to smack me to let me
know that you could get me that's cool
and we would go there and kill each
other we'd do a class first we'd do a
forum class
one of us fuji
kung fu he always had beautiful forms
yeah so we'd do some of his forms and
then we'd just [ __ ]
kill each other just destroy each other
oh my god yeah that [ __ ] wall had
holes and i remember his chinese father
came down one day and threw us out get
the [ __ ] out
i got two thousand holes in my balls
[ __ ]
because you missed the opponent
everybody was everybody was a kicker
yeah everybody was bruce lee that
everybody would fight you in a horse
dance
everybody had a straight up sidekick
everybody did the cat noise
yeah
america was doing the cat noise yeah
bruce lee died i know
three of us me pino and [ __ ] mike
we walked around devastated for six
months like we didn't believe it yeah
and then the [ __ ] chinese people you
know they got no respect when it comes
to dollars
they started sending over all these
bruce lies
oh yeah yeah
yeah the first [ __ ] i tried to
break through was
i gotta think of the commercial yeah
hong kong
step aside bruce lee and make way for
corrado the hong kong cat and this guy
had new trucks only with copper on the
bottom of them you know copper tubing
for plumbing oh yeah he added up and he
ended up a step and the movie starts
where he's [ __ ] two guys up and all
of a sudden that corrado come in for
dinner and he's like i mean i'll see you
guys tomorrow and he goes in the house
on the east i forget the plot yeah he's
a punctual badass but that once that
[ __ ] started i tried like i never even
went to see gamer death the first time
like when they released games
at together yeah yeah i didn't go none
of those i was done all those
all those bruce i didn't go to the
first festival i went to was 93 his 20th
anniversary they did this thing they
released dragon in new york i was there
oh yeah
i went to the festival was pretty cool
yeah dragon was pretty good yeah pretty
[ __ ] good
there's like a disney version of right
you know bruce lee's real life you know
and then show them people spitting at
him and calling him you ching [ __ ] and
all that [ __ ] yeah
which was the truth you didn't really
[ __ ] dig them at first you know then
when they started digging them the
chinese started hating them
because he's teaching kung fu to white
people and they're like dog you can't be
teaching kung fu to white people that's
our secret weapon that's gonna [ __ ]
these [ __ ] up 2017.
but he shows a few white people
then it's in every strip mall across the
country between a dry cleaners and a
hoagie shop you know
it was crazy
karate schools were mobbed yeah
karate schools every teacher
started at 2 3 30
and he didn't get out of there till 10
and it was all hour classes yeah you
know kids advanced kids
men's uh 13 to 15
21 and then if you were good 13 to 15
you could stay until 10 and spar in the
whole thing and that was me yeah i was
one of those nerds man so [ __ ]
sophomore year in high school
i would hang out with those morons on
the weekends who
you know when i stopped hanging out with
them is when i started doing drugs like
i couldn't do drugs around yeah so i had
my reefer friends and my drinking
friends and i had my karate friends my
karate friends went to the city on
saturdays and we went to karate stores
honda yeah we would sit there and dream
someday i'm gonna get that pad
you know wow it's 56 that's a lot of
money and then we get like a protein
drink in the city and we'd go to a
chinatown and go to a kung fu movie my
other buddies were like [ __ ] it we'd
smoke a joint and do thc crystal gorilla
biscuits jesus christ angel dustin we go
into chinatown yeah eat that leather and
buy fireworks and stolen [ __ ]
either way you're throwing chinese stars
at something yeah right we would buy
chinese stars but there was it was only
one thing with chinese stars they never
came sharpened
so yeah go home and start throwing them
at people and nothing would happen they
would just go ouch
and you're expecting the [ __ ] star to
stick in their arms
you had to find somebody to [ __ ]
sharpen them then people were like nine
sharpen them there was one guy we found
and a hardware store in the bronx he'll
sharpen anything he'll sharpen anything
for three bucks was he in the hardware
store just like behind the hardware
store like yeah
they can't have little kids with
just throwing stars
especially yeah when you buy those stars
you could buy them at right around the
corner in lancaster yeah you can buy
them anywhere at jean labelle's place
yeah there's only one by the way they're
not [ __ ] sharp no you got to get
those things to somebody who's got that
yeah and do all four sides and you can
cut a finger you have to put like your
finger don't those things go until they
can't come out or something terrible
things are a nightmare when those things
are sharp you could [ __ ] somebody's
world up with those things jesus don't
give him ideas i had a friend one time
throw a dart at his brother it was
brilliant
we still talk about it when we get
together barbecue
she was giving him [ __ ] he was giving
her [ __ ] and she was playing darts
and she's gonna start and she's like say
that to me one more time
those [ __ ] dots that you throw at the
wall like yeah they stick in the pad and
people playing bars darts okay there's
small ones i thought it was
it was a pool party yeah and everybody
was having a good time and it was
brother sister they got into an argument
his sister's like say that again to me
and i [ __ ] throw this dog at your
head
and he called me like a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
he goes really and she just started
whipping stars trying to block him and
two of them went right into his kneecap
and i don't forget him going down going
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you when i pull
this [ __ ] thing
and then pulling it out like nothing
like it
it was just another day at the [ __ ]
thing
what's up steve brown talk to me brother
dude good to be here thank you so much
for having me how was the special how
was the the
reports showtime special yeah it was
good yeah they were all happy with it uh
people checked it out uh it's on
showtime now you could stream it
called tell the damn joke and you know i
i you know i'm not one of those guys
that has an hour every year like some
people
i try to do it every two
two and a half years maybe three because
i want it to be
pretty good but i think like hours are
done now hours are not special anymore
because there's so many i think they're
it's like it's like the tv show is
almost like the new hour special because
to get that it's really difficult it's
hard to get whereas nowadays
i mean you remember 10 years ago to get
a comedy central half hour was
almost unattainable you had to really
work your ass off for it but then
everybody got it and now with cso and
netflix and showtime hbo and everything
now it's like every time you turn your
head there's no building there's a new
hour
yeah and it's kind of like weird because
now they're going to become very oh i
don't need to watch this one i'll just
wait till i get 10 of them yeah and
watch them all at one time like binge
watching
i watched tj miller's yep i didn't i
don't have showtime so i don't know i
don't know about my wife but what
happened she goes i took it out of the
package because we don't watch anything
dexter got cancelled i didn't [ __ ]
know
i didn't even know what to do i
consulted on this i was what you were
not consulted on this decision no how
was tj's special
um different yeah for hbo it was very
different i applaud him you know he's
always been different though he's always
eccentric and taking chances and risks
yeah yeah yeah you know it was different
i watched it two times you know i can't
watch and watch anybody's special whole
hour yeah i watch the first half hour
digest it i think about something i go
back watch half of it and then watch the
rest of it and see how he does the the
whole sequence and the whole thing yeah
he's a neat kid man he's a good dude too
of it but i i think it's it's weird
because like if you're a musician
like you hear all those stories about
the beatles and hendricks and the beach
boys they're all listening to each other
and influencing each other
and i think some stand-up stand-up isn't
like that though i don't think most
stand-ups sit down and watch other
comics i think stand-ups are just more
isolated and they aren't willing to be
influenced because i think
your part of you is scared
of like
something bleeding through and taking
away from your own individuality i guess
but uh
i don't know it's like i haven't seen an
hour special a long time until
chappelle's two came out and then i was
like i'm watching these what did you
think i thought the first one was
[ __ ] great and the second one was
good
really i thought yeah i thought the
opposite
really yeah everybody has different
opinions yeah
it's um but they're still great you know
what i mean they're still it's like it's
still him he's at the top of his game he
always is but um
i thought the first one was just like
[ __ ] lights out my favorite thing
steve burns
as a comic number two like you know you
have your favorite things as a [ __ ]
i love getting high
and sneaking into the original
yeah and sitting in the back in the old
days when nobody used to be back there
no
10 years ago there was nobody back there
yeah so you could sit back there and
people thought you were a customer with
a glass of water yeah they didn't know
you were a comic
and i love getting there by 10 after 9.
even though your spots are 11 yeah
getting nice and stoned and just sitting
watching comedy yeah and it used to be
the best for me
like just to see why these guys were at
the comedy store yeah like i used to say
which one let's see what the [ __ ]
there's got to be something yeah you
know sometimes we're in there we get off
stage we killed and somebody goes up
there we watch for three minutes but
where energy's flying we can't sit in
there though long that's it the original
i gotta get the [ __ ] out of it i gotta
breathe i need some i just did 15
[ __ ] minutes and worked my ass off
but there's times for me to watch comedy
i gotta tell you something guys
it doesn't work for me at the house
sorry not anymore
doesn't come even my special first time
i watched 20 minutes
oh you're you're on yeah like yeah i
don't see so but it's tough to watch
it's still the best way i love that i
still realize
after 26 years that
i still loved when i used to go to the
comedy works
as a [ __ ] construction estimate yeah
and i'd sit in the back and drool and go
[ __ ] how do i do this
yeah every now and then like at the
store i'll
i'll be walking through and i'm like
i'll just watch it's really good i saw
garland the other night i was watching
garland and he just was on this rant and
it was so [ __ ] funny and i was just i
became a customer and it's been a long
time since i wasn't a medium judging or
whatever it's really a [ __ ] great
thing it's dying you leave that feeling
really good even if it's my bomb yeah
yeah like this night you're going on
that you look at your schedule and you
go who's up there you know what what am
i gonna do sit in the house and torture
myself to [ __ ] 10 45. that's what you
do at eight o'clock you're like why am i
here yeah i'm gonna write down like no
no i'm not yeah i'm gonna play with the
kid or go on a [ __ ] computer and see
what's on facebook let me just go down
there well that's the great thing about
the store though is that is the
camaraderie too is that
the other night i got these kids now i
got the wife you know i drive out from
pasadena i go into the store i do my set
fun crowd fun room sebastian's up next
i'm like you know i haven't seen him in
a while i'm gonna watch sebastian i
watch sebastian dying dying ross goes up
jeff ross watch him [ __ ] dying two
different styles two different styles
two different styles and then ross and i
i go dude those are so [ __ ] great
what are you doing i'm like i was gonna
go come have a drink with me we have a
drink next thing i know we're at some
buddy's birthday party in the hills then
we go down uh one oak we're going to one
oak mike young is at a booth
it's just like it remi it made me feel
like i was 20 again it was like i'm
hanging out with comics it's saturday i
had no intention of going out and i just
had like the greatest night it was
because of ross and mike young and
sebastian and
the store is the best i
love this kid i love lee siam with all
my heart
and i thought that from time to time he
would surprise me
nothing yeah i gotta surprise this poor
[ __ ] kid yeah you know when i was 28
i would surprise you every other week
you know as it was yeah yeah yeah
machine gun i got something for you yeah
28 this is how i live
this guy's watching orange is the new
black diamond again you're all right for
the first time i wouldn't [ __ ] talk
him out of getting married he'd be
shacked up already yeah no but the other
night i went down to the store on the
sunday i watched paul mooney
yeah you know and when i was at the
store in the beginning he was the guy
that i followed yes he sure just
made me follow him and just walking in
there and seeing him then don't you want
to go back and talk to him and i'm like
you know what
not really yeah
just seeing him brings back all these
memories
and sometimes you [ __ ] need that man
yeah we do
yeah i think that you know
it's weird because it goes in absent
flows like i did this hour special i put
it out there you know you work your ass
off for two and a half years you put it
out and a few years ago you put it on
our special you get some tweets back oh
great
everything's so diluted now
because there's so many they're flooding
the market with gold and i feel like
these corporations
and i don't blame them they got to find
content they've got to provide you know
content for their for their subscribers
so they're doing what they can and
comedy's so cheap so they're making all
these hour specials but i feel like
all these different networks that are
doing that
are putting out all this content and
eventually it's going to get saturated
and the people that are going to suffer
the most
are the comics because we're going to
have to go through this period again
where after the 80s in the 90s there was
this lull and then the internet came in
dane cook blew it up and then slowly
uh
i think the internet helped advance so
many comics to get their word out to get
the material out
and i mean look at like louie i mean the
guy's releasing [ __ ] on his website and
that wasn't possible 10 or 15 years ago
because there was no internet you know
prior to like you know all the
capabilities we have now so i just think
it's a weird time for stand-up and
me personally when i put the hour out i
was so proud and everything but
i i just
i just needed to be inspired again and
going there and then seeing everybody
and seeing all the great work and seeing
you know just all the i don't know just
being in the shop again
got me like you know you got to get back
to work no you got to go you know
you got to go to this yeah
listen
i'm 54. when i walk in the store
i feel like a pedophile number one
number two i still remember being
37
and being a regular at the snow i know
these 50 year olds that would sit there
at night like
begging for a spot yeah has to feel bad
for them
listen i could get five spots a week if
i call yeah i just don't i don't you
know i'll go to the haha i'll go to
[ __ ]
you know flappers i hide i like to hide
i love going to the ice house you know
but if i go to the store once a week
that's going to batting cages for me
enough yeah problem with the store is
you go down there you have a 10 30 spot
you do bump into something you haven't
seen in a while yeah
you go in the back you have a drink you
smoke a joint i just had to drive up a
borrow canyon dog
you know what i'm yeah yeah it's not
here in hollywood and i'm listening i'm
too old to leave my car and come back in
the [ __ ] morning yeah yeah that
worked when you're 35. people understood
that when you're 54 like really
you know what's saying you still got
okay
so it just feels really weird but going
to the store
is still a star it's still a stripe on
my shirt
yeah look when you think about all the
great clubs the store started it you
know
and the fact that
you're part of that legacy you're part
of that history you're part of one of
those bricks that will always be there
i mean to get your name painted on the
on the wall it's still to this day
yeah you can get those hour specials but
it's a very select few that get past the
commie seller it's a very very select
few that get passed at the comedy store
and i think
that's really the badge of honor at the
end of the day when all this is said and
done one day i'm going to take my kids
and go i was a regular here i used to
come here all the time and i was part of
this history and it'll still be around
and i know there would be some relevant
comics back then but to know that these
kids get to go my dad did that [ __ ]
that's pretty [ __ ] yeah my dad your
dad's name is right up on that wall
pretty sweet all right so i got here
january 29th
i get to the improv in those days it was
when did you get here
2004. all right so i was here seven
years ahead of you so what i got here
was supposed to be the big latin
explosion
toughest ticket on monday night was the
last friday latinos i couldn't get in
there
people line up outside pablo
oh yeah paul carlos
[ __ ] crazy pablo was unreal yeah when
he did seinfeld in spanish and [ __ ]
oh my god i was like what the [ __ ] yeah
and then the improv had a latin night so
because of latin night i got passed in
the improv right away yeah
and then the laugh factory he hated me
jamie but gilbert ran monday night
so monday night i got spots i got
20-minute spots that's all that mattered
he wouldn't even step foot in there on
monday nights he didn't he didn't know
who's going up on mondays
so that was good the comedy store was
the one that since day one people always
came up to me and said
mitchie was here yeah yeah you don't
know and then go oh boy
that's your club yeah
what are you talking about angel salazar
i worked with him and he's like bro
wait till mitzi sees you and i'm like
really yeah and sure enough
i was part of the club i was a regular
within a month
wow
i was here i got i got became i got here
january 19th i became a regular on my
birthday oh [ __ ] february 19th really i
wasn't even here a month but i got on
the list and they said six months
waiting list yeah doug stanhope
sponsored me
and somebody else
it was like two or three people called
scott day
okay and scott they called me on a
friday at six dog and he goes listen
i gotta fall out for sunday you want to
go up in front of mitzi yeah
[ __ ] yeah oh my god yeah i was like this
is it i went up did three minutes
she goes can you come back next week and
do 10. [ __ ] yeah yeah are you really
cute and i like you and people
[Laughter]
you know maybe you should just up like
fidel and get a beard and go up there
and tell jokes people would like that
i'm like okay
and i'm like i hope she's not serious
yeah and the next week i went up there
did my ten and she's like you're a
wrangling ah that's great and i was like
oh my god but i couldn't get a manager
could not get an agent
could not get anybody to talk to me
montreal [ __ ] you yeah it was like a
[ __ ] you fest
but the only person who gave me spots
every week was mitsy t-shirts all that
mattered cause you're doing the work and
it didn't really matter those days it
was like you know what [ __ ] [ __ ] you
yeah [ __ ] you i'm following paul mooney
yeah four nights a week what have you
done lately [ __ ]
and i've died all four nights but what
have you done
eventually you figure out the puzzle
yeah and that's what that forced me to
do yeah like paul mooney i i like i
always tell people richard pryor showed
me the door
paul mooney really showed me how to go
through it because he was always on
before me yep and i didn't know how long
he was going to do so i'd have to sit
there
sometimes it was 25
sometimes it was 45 sometimes it was 55
but i'd be watching him
and for the first three months i
couldn't figure out the puzzle of
following it was not going up there and
doing your 8 30 show material yeah it's
quarter to one take that material and
light it on fire and save that for old
people at a casino because this ain't
gonna work at the store at 12 45 yeah it
makes you [ __ ] just start talking
fast
yeah yeah yeah well yeah i mean when i
was at the comedy cellar
my first seven years
lampanelli or i did the 145
or 130 spots so we had to close out the
show
and so
chappelle would come in people comics
would leave
oh i'm going home because he'd do two
hours three hours but i never left i
always [ __ ] stayed i always stayed
and i was like i'm gonna follow him
you know 23 24 years old you're not
following him you're like what i was
really doing was learning how to follow
the puzzle yeah exactly crack the puzzle
yeah so
oh those seven years
chappelle chris rock seinfeld
robin williams didn't matter i was like
fearless i was like i will follow
anybody because that's why i'm here i'm
here to learn and i always knew that
early on that i'm gonna i'm gonna use
this as like the comedy seller was
college to me
and uh yeah i think it's i think
ultimately what you realize after
following all those people is the
audience
i think a young comic goes oh [ __ ] how
am i gonna
match chappelle how am i gonna be on the
same scale it's like you're not because
once chappelle leaves the audience has
flipped the page yeah they're excited
but
showtime go we're waiting let's go let's
get to your [ __ ] [ __ ] so you got to
smash them quick and you got to keep
that train going otherwise you're going
to die exactly all the things that
you're thinking as you're sitting in the
back of the room oh my god you sit back
there
and you're like oh [ __ ]
and then they would close like david
paul mooney wouldn't even bring you up
yeah oh he'd just leave he just put the
mic in and say oh
[ __ ]
negroes and you had to run up then go
keep it going for paul mooney
and the nut like if you said something
else about paul mooney yeah you just
died yeah like i figured that out quick
every time you go but movie is a funny
guy keep it going for one more time the
godfather you just died yeah you just
died now they're gonna go okay so he's
the godfather what do you got for us
yeah no you got to go up there and keep
it going for paul mooney what's
happening you bad [ __ ] and you
just got to jump on them yeah you [ __ ]
suckers it's 12 45 i'm here to sling
dick and give out bubble gum i got a
gram of rock in my pocket i'm ready to
snort some blow and eat somebody's
[ __ ] and then you go into material
yeah all right you got our attention you
fumigated the room
you just fumigated the room yeah so now
we're down to eight but i'm getting that
15
yeah at the store it was the battle for
fifteen dollars like they had battle for
network stars they brought it back yeah
at the store it was like listen joy
there's three people
but if you want to go to 15 we'll let
you go up for one
we'll go sit in there like that it was
that bad yeah
you need to fit 15 15 000 in those days
yeah five more i got a 20 from chewie
but
you learned oh yeah let me tell you
something that comedy teaches you
when you bite into comedy you eliminate
one of the biggest fears in your life
there's something about getting into
stand-up comedy that that's where the
biggest high is because
from the beginning
when you come to me lee with your three
best friends me lee
and tom segura and we're [ __ ]
construction workers and we giggle and
you come to all three of us one night
and go so tuesday night is my first open
mic guy and we all look here like this
is pittsburgh what open mic you're
talking about steve burke
i'm gonna try comedy man i've always
wanted to be a comedian
all three of us are gonna [ __ ] laugh
at you or whatever and goof on you yeah
i'm gonna tell you we love you and we'll
be down there to support you and you're
gonna bomb and we're gonna crack jokes
on you for the next three weeks and [ __ ]
yeah you're gonna crack some jokes in
that or something or you're gonna
whisper that night you're on stage and
they're gonna call you [ __ ] stevie
whispers
something you know what i'm saying
there's always something
and there's so much to overcome plus the
income factor
especially early on yeah that's the
toughest that's the toughest thing yeah
so when you make that commitment and the
one day you go that's it i'm gonna
become financially independent doing
comedy yeah i made 800 bucks last month
if i made 800 last month i'm gonna go
for 900 this month yeah and you actually
make 9.25 and let me go for 1100 and
that's what it becomes it really becomes
but that first 300
it's hard yeah that for like whenever i
started comedy my lucky thing was i was
making 200 a month doing comedy my first
year economy i made 2400 as a host at a
restaurant
tuesdays from eight to ten two hundred a
month they gave me your menu i go in
there during the week and all the
sauvignon blanc and they gotta put it on
my tuesday time
whatever the [ __ ] it is i don't know why
but that was i made money from the
beginning 200 a month that don't do
nothing but i would also sell valium
so my shows on tuesday i would make you
buy a ticket they thought i was selling
tickets but not really
steve marin you wanted something yeah
where can i meet you meet me at the
broker at 8 30. what's going on in the
brook i'm doing comedy do i have to pay
to get in yeah 10 bucks who gives a [ __ ]
i'm gonna give you the best coke in town
i'll see you at 11 30. i just hang up on
you and then steve burns comes and he
pays for a ticket yeah i give him the
bag give him a gram and maybe a quality
gives me 90 bucks i gave me a little
extra thanks for coming i'm saying
sit down get a drink i'm telling like i
did a contest yeah and after the first
week i watched it and i realized this
guy didn't win because he was funny
this guy won because he brought 11
idiots from his job yeah yeah yeah so
the first time i did i brought like
eight people i won i was the funniest
that night though [ __ ] those
[ __ ]
then the second time i didn't bring
nobody and i still won
the second time i didn't bring nobody
then the third time it was for the
finals and i brought about 20 people
from my gambling job
and i won yeah and then for the night i
won i bought in like 118 [ __ ]
80 of them looking for a package of blow
i made them stay till the end till i got
the 510 and i'll check them out oh there
you go that's great i got the 500
checking my hand i celebrated cocaine
for everybody
i figured out that if i sold drugs at
the places i get people to come yeah i
didn't do it in new york i would do it
sometimes in new york i would go to new
york comedy club you got to bring three
people yeah people would say to me if
you're going into the city can you pick
something up for me and i go absolutely
are you going to meet me in this thing
and then go yeah i go do me a favor go
to new york comedy club at eight o'clock
i'm doing four minutes
yeah and i'll give you the coke when i'm
there or sometimes i make them come and
i make them give me a ride doll you
didn't get it yet now i gotta go to
holla [ __ ] we thought you were
gonna have it i was but i got chased by
the cops
yeah but the toughest i think like
especially at the beginning yeah you
worry about how am i gonna make money
that's the toughest thing the
psychologically the toughest thing once
you try stand up the first time it'll
never get scarier than that you already
did it
the first time you do it
is the most
that's that's the trial by fire because
the whole time you're you're you're
waiting to do it you're scared as [ __ ]
how's this gonna go you have no idea you
don't have any wherewithal of what
you're doing or comprehending anything
you can't read the crowd you don't know
how to do crowd work you don't know to
do material because you don't have
material i think once you finish that
first time some people get scared off
after doing the first time like i can
never do that again it's like it'll
never get harder than than what you just
did
now you have some semblance of
experience so you can only get better
from there because at least now you kind
of got a lay of the land but so many
people cut tail and run after that first
time which uh you know it's fine but for
me
i was always at the mindset of like once
you did it it's like it's all downhill
from here
like this [ __ ] guy look at him
once he ate a pot cookie he was all
downhill after that okay yeah when when
whenever you ever had a single
edible
yeah i'm okay how long was your
procrastination period steve burns from
the thought to getting on stage
oh uh well i worked at caroline's comedy
club uh you know just sweeping the
floors and answering the phones never
been to a stand-up show ever in my life
and then uh i started i watched like a
new talent showcase that i had on
thursday nights at caroline so i was
like that looks like [ __ ] fun
so four months
four months i worked up the nerve and i
wrote some stuff i thought was funny and
i went up at stand-up new york
for my first set ever went really well
and then the next week i went to new
york comedy club and this guy named
roger paul was in the audience and uh he
gave me his card he goes how long you
been doing i go
twice he goes what i go i've been on
stage twice he goes meet me tomorrow so
i met him and i had a manager
after my second time on stage and then
he started putting me on the road i was
emceeing i was making [ __ ] money but i
didn't give a [ __ ] it you know the money
didn't mean anything to me i was i was
working doing that stage time that's all
that matters i'm gonna take you to fire
roger
[Laughter]
i think uh maybe like two years here two
years but then i was i was working
once i got passed at the seller all the
clubs in new york city fell like
dominoes
and the seller was the first club i got
past that then the comic strip then
gotham then stand up new york all the
clubs fell online and then all of a
sudden i just stayed in new york for
five six years i just stayed in new york
and i made a living doing eight or nine
spots on a friday eight or nine spots on
a saturday and i would make you know you
make 75 100 a set i mean that's good
money for 23 24 i was able to live in
the city in manhattan just doing
stand-up for seven years and then got a
half hour out of that and then um
i started seeing all the comics in new
york and i was like
they all kind of plateaued and there's
only i was like not a lot of these guys
are all funny but they don't have shows
they're not in movies
and i was like
i gotta move to l.a because these guys
have conquered new york i conquered new
york but i want more i want everybody i
want everything and that's when i moved
to l.a
did you want movies in the beginning
when you first got to stand up did you
think about it no i just thought about
stand-up because i was so
infatuated that
like you said it was like the greatest
high i i'm not a drug guy or anything i
drink whiskey but it's like nothing
to me in life compares to
having a notebook writing something just
the thought and then going that night to
the club and slowly figuring out the
puzzle how to piece it together
and to me that is the greatest
it's so redemptive i i don't know
there's just nothing better than that
other than you know my family i still
can't believe i do it
like when i'm in a car i don't wait on
an airport i can't believe what just
happened i just did five shows
people showed up they laughed i took a
bunch of pictures
and right before i'm getting out of the
car at the airport i'm like how the [ __ ]
did this happen yeah
and i think back to 94
drive 93 driving a limo in l.a and then
uh
new york and stopping at new york comedy
club in those days i think i did new
york comedy club and something else
uptown and everything else was hamburger
hilly's yo yeah yeah old triple funny
yeah holy [ __ ] yeah oh i used to do all
that all those yeah that's so
triple in look at this poor bastard
yellow triple in opened up at 11. you
didn't get on yeah that's down 30. two
blocks from the ceiling you know yeah it
was something that
when i went to new york i realized how
hard i had to work yeah like i had to
really go well if i want to do this
this is what i need to do what i'm doing
right now is completely unacceptable
yeah
but i can't do this in this large scale
you know 181st street was my house i
could go there with 25 bucks and get a
gram of tremendous cocaine yeah and it
was always my pit stop whether i was
going over or coming back
you always got 25 bucks yeah i would go
ahead but they were open until two you
know yeah and they were always there you
know so
i was like i'm never gonna grow with
that [ __ ] that accessible yeah it's
everywhere i don't mind driving a half
hour but that kind of deters it for a
guy like me but this [ __ ] i'm just
walking a mile because i lived in fort
lee yeah yeah i could just walk over the
bridge hook a left walk around boom yeah
right there yeah and then i'd take an a
train down
and i'd take the bus back over port
authority so the cops wouldn't even see
that's right they're right on the west
side
good deal joey bananas
ounces of coke and nobody would ever
know everybody's getting pulled over
because they're watching for cars yeah
and they would go how the [ __ ] do you do
it like go watch me yeah i'd walk over
the bridge like nothing happened
make the left walk pick up three four
ounces of blow
walk over get a cuban meal and a hundred
and like 76th street and going away
and then i'd walk down to the train
station and i'd take the a train down
walk around 42nd street for two three
minutes it's got a steak on a stick with
the white bread you don't mean dog i'm
the only real deal if you got hepatitis
i got it
i was the first one buying those steaks
on the sticks from arabs and putting
frank's hot sauce on him with a can of
coke
that was my [ __ ] diet for about a
year in nyc though yeah
my spot was the guy right outside
the [ __ ] port authority across from
porno world
before they cleaned it up there was a
big point and then the laugh actually
moved in there for a while yeah yeah
right there with him have you across the
street that's the movie theaters right
there yeah right there he was right
there for years you walked by he'd be
cooking those little goat meat on a
steak i didn't give a [ __ ] yeah you know
i had sixty-two dollars yeah if i was
going to coke
you know i still needed beer and three
bucks for goat meat sure this no it was
two dollars two bucks for a piece of
wonder bread come on you know who's
better than you
frank's
yeah
that new york living was hard for me
that was too yeah 93. really
where did you live in new york i lived
in fort lee i took uh i signed up for a
boxing gym yeah port authority ran
across the street upstairs in the second
floor
60 a month and they gave me a locker
so i had my suiting an extra pair of
jeans toothbrush hair gel t-shirts
shorts just in case you're in the city
you got to rock and roll you have an
audition
you know me and yesterday i was johnny
hustle i was horrifically bad
horrifically bad i would go to auditions
and they would just look at me and go oh
god
i thought i wanted to be an improv guy
yeah and the only character i had was
one a junkie
like do your famous character and i
would not then go yeah man and he began
new newspaper
what else do you got that's it thank you
for coming
they just saw 85 junkies everybody in
new york was a junkie in those days so
like i just was it wasn't working for me
so i said for me to really make it work
i got to move back to colorado but if i
move back to colorado i'll make a deal
with myself my whole focus will be stand
up yeah
seven nights a week
six six [ __ ] every [ __ ] night and
that's exactly what i did yeah i made it
my focus for a year and a half i always
thought i know this sounds so stupid but
that sinatra song new york new york that
line if you can make it there you can
make it true i always felt that way and
i always thought one day you're gonna
feel like you when you feel like you did
enough in new york
that's when you move and when i was
doing
again like nine shows a night on a
friday or saturday every club i was pat
i was like you did it as a comic you've
done every [ __ ] room you can do
so why not go get the rest of the
questions danger fields too oh
dangerfield yo yeah that was my spot
because that was the only place in the
city you could do 30 minutes a 30-minute
set
and that's great do you still do it i
haven't been in danger fields in
probably 10 12 years i i stopped in
probably 12 years ago to say hi to the
staff and have a drink and that was kind
of it
but uh i've never performed there i like
to perform there before they close it
someday you should still use rotary
phones
from back in the day and the the thing i
loved about performing at dangerfields
wasn't necessarily
the crowds because there was never
crowds there unless it was friday
saturday it's bridging tunnel coming in
and out we gotta go you know take the
old lady to dangerfield it's a hot spot
right but monday tuesday man there's
[ __ ] nobody there but the best was
tony the owner he had all these stories
about dangerfield and i would just sit
and just tell me another story and he
had all these great [ __ ] stories
about dangerfield like like when they
did the uh premiere for caddyshack in
hollywood
um
all the stars are pulling up in front of
man's chinese theater
limos chevy chase comes up in a limo ted
knight comes up with a limo
and dangerfield you know no respect
he pulls up in a tow truck and his car
is getting towed by the tow truck and he
gets out and he tips the tow truck
driver calling make a loop around i'll
be back in him and he's saying i might
take a picture it's just like
that is so [ __ ] funny to me that he
even even at the premiere he was like
it's still no respect i gotta i gotta
get a joke out of this [ __ ] so funny
i love them oh god
it's uh
still still this day kills by the way i
mean you could go back and watch your
danger
damn it it's so [ __ ] funny i [ __ ]
it's i don't know what happened
i think i saw him on the tonight show
and then there was a word on the street
that he was in the movie
and that's it like yeah everybody i know
like six of us
i'll never forget that it was a hot
summer day
we bought beers like these guys showed
up with beers now like we're going to
the new rodney murray i'm like
and it was easy money
oh yeah yeah
that's how old i am dawg
easy money in the movie theater billy
joel did the theme song oh my god
easy money i remember that yeah and he's
going through the paperwork and he's
finding money and he has tickets and
rolling papers
and then did you write that movie sounds
like your life oh
joey
no you know man they were thinking of
redoing it yeah they won't redo it the
wife said yeah not in a million years
and i gotta respect it
if they redid it i'd like joe pesci's
part yeah joe passes back off the
[ __ ] chain he was a good
when the scene opens and he's trimming
his armpit hair
he lives in his mother's house that's
all hysterical yeah
unless you're part of that the wedding
with the puerto rican yeah
call me dad
i'll let you call me dad all that [ __ ]
is classic she that chick that played
the daughter she went on to become yeah
somebody [ __ ] huge i still use
that line from when the mother walks in
and says look at you
your eyes are bloodshot
and you smell of
reefer and alcohol and god knows what
else is something yeah and he slays it
uh
and then all that scene about you know
where uh it's shaken back really
where's your father he's taking baby
pictures what type of baby is up at nine
o'clock at night they go right to a
strip club yeah he's like show it to me
that's a classic scene yeah and then joe
pesci gets into it
the guy grabs the chick he grabs the
tits the guy comes out and goes oh
what's going on and joe's like oh what's
going on here and he goes who are you
who am i who am i i'm the guy that put
the bathrooms in this joint
and if you know anything about east
coast people that's that's so yeah every
once in a while somebody who am i
who am i
you know who i am right you know my
cousin is yeah wait who's your cousin
let me tell you come here
nikki tuna who's nikki tuna
you know like you're like what the [ __ ]
yeah
and you're like okay i get it your
cousin's in the mob or something
but then so you know why oh my yeah oh
my i gotta put the bathrooms in this
truck i don't know what i don't know i
don't know what this is supposed to do
for that guy what do you do for the guy
who put the bathrooms in the place
are you supposed to respect him in his
mind and then the guy says to him no
wonder the place smells like [ __ ]
jumps over yeah and then they're at the
restaurant they're trying to eat all his
food that scene is brilliant yeah the
most brilliant scene in that movie
that not too many people catch is him
and whatever at the park eating hot dogs
but
he gets something different
and they're sitting there
and all of a sudden he's like i don't
know if this diet is going to
he says it's gotta work you gotta do it
for your family if you're gonna do it
for love
hello joe bishops look at that guy over
there you see that that's real love and
they show a guy with a rain jack on
bouncing a kill off his thing with a hat
on like very incognito yeah rubbing the
kids back
and joe pressu
you see that
oh
you see that that's love look at the way
that no
rodney's selling it to nicki [ __ ] you
see that's love look at the way he's
bouncing that kid off his lap that's her
father's love and all of a sudden the
mother comes into the scene
with the cop
and she goes there he is my little
precious jimmy and he goes who's this
and he goes i don't know i was just
sitting here minding my own business and
the kid jumped on my lap and he goes can
i see an id
and very suddenly you hear the guy goes
id it's in my other rain jacket
you don't really hear it but you hear it
like that is a brilliant that like that
movie had so many little subtle funny
yeah all those movies from the 80s still
make me i just watched
when i watch on the road two days ago
and i gotta tell you something it took
me for a mental ride yeah
breakfast club oh great yeah
breakfast club will [ __ ] with your head
you'll think about a bunch of [ __ ] you
were doing back in the 80s eating [ __ ]
and [ __ ] yeah
everybody's eating somebody's [ __ ] like
molly ringwall i had a girlfriend like
molly ring what a freckle and a [ __ ] i
loved it
those redheads always got a freckle
somewhere that teddy's that [ __ ]
i had a girlfriend just like molly ring
wall falling but i love those redheads
yeah
ginger
pale yeah i love redheads yeah pale but
they gotta have a little color too i
don't i don't see you as a discerner i
think anything what do you mean would
you uh back in the day anything right as
a dude
i don't like shrug girls
that's not
too bad yeah i don't like shortstop like
a gymnast
yeah i don't like uh i don't like that i
mean pussy's [ __ ] but i don't like it
i want to be i want a little sleeker a
little taller yeah i like them around
five six five seven
i like a woman that'll take an elbow and
i call
happens from 911 to time that's a joke
people
[Laughter]
you know i like them sometimes built
yep you know i like them dirty like that
chick at the comedy store the one
waitress that's big girl she's from
michigan big girl she always wears yoga
pants her ass is huge i would tear that
ass up if i wasn't a married dude she's
even she even has a dirty look to her
like she goes to work without washing
her bush
like she's one of those girls that
leaves she washes everything else but
watches in the morning
she goes at eight and watches a monkey
but yeah she goes to work without
washing the monkey and you go up and
down those [ __ ] belly room stairs 10
times
out of that monkey i'm saying
every time i see you i'm like a [ __ ] so
[ __ ] good right now yeah
i could taste it and [ __ ] i'm like
hannibal lecter from long distance
[Laughter]
i don't know what got into me
really you ready for three more stars we
gotta take it to the next limit i don't
think i think we have enough stars no no
no no no we're gonna eat three more
stars steve burns is here it's a
beautiful night to be alive what the
[ __ ] yeah you know what i'm saying
that's the mission this week
i'm leaving tomorrow
i'm gonna take the family on a little
two-day [ __ ]
vacation yeah from time to time steve
burns if not they get cagey you know
what i'm saying yeah smell that steep
breeze tell the people at home what that
smells like oh jesus christ
yeah
done look boom one more out of respect
i'll have one more sure like there's one
more there's two more two more okay i
just take two come on let's go what the
[ __ ] let's go
one more out of respect it's [ __ ]
monday night i'm going to see you the
rest of the week
who loves you oh there it is i look good
it's still here lee let's leave it alone
yeah i want to see what direction it
goes did it come to me because
yeah i just saved you
whoa there he goes god damn it are you
gonna eat this
no yes he's gonna eat that he has no
choice it's monday night he has a little
containment everybody likes no no no no
this is you because you eat pizza in
here you eat chips and you get uber eats
at night you're [ __ ]
that's right you get uber eats and i eat
that stop please you gotta catch up to
me two stars come on let's go come on
come on what's the difference lee what
the [ __ ] so
she says questions she is talking this
is like he just got divorced and she
took a half every day everything
you don't even know she took everything
she's an attorney he married an attorney
yeah he's done
even if she moves on now she's taking
three-quarters of the furniture by
california law
this [ __ ] mobile game finishes
november he gave her half the fortune
this [ __ ] momo he just met her on the
street on mets.com
he gave her half the fortune two one
more year she's eligible to all your
guinness did you know that there's
nothing
two more years that's it two years your
common law marriage in california you
kick her out she takes half your salary
[ __ ] nut you'll be doing 22 podcasts a
day just to survive
you're lucky i'm your uncle joey you
know what i'm saying you'll be
podcasting in your sleep
lee are you okay oh yeah he's always
okay to start getting overweight please
why are you insulting me
look at poor
ain't a piece of chocolate she's in the
stretch
oh this is a party here steve brad
look at this one star i hate two of them
back to back to back
come on lee please you're insulting me
look at him he's sweating profusely
no i'm not i'm dry as [ __ ] you wanna do
a bucket no really oh my god
see and this doesn't end when the
recording stops and it's not like joey
anthony's like proper he's like oh
that's a good show
this goes for hours do you want to bonk
it you want another star what do you
think i'm sitting here i got to be a
good host
we're not going to have you sit here if
you don't want to do bunkers we do bang
hits maybe he loves you dude he cares
about it
this is how friends treat each other you
don't know that if i had whiskey i'd be
offering it to steve brown yeah he liked
whiskey but he's driving also sorry i'm
driving yeah i'm driving
but yeah but it's a different kind of
friendship you're using a different kind
of friendship yeah you live four blocks
you ain't bothering nobody yeah you
don't even see a cop on the ride home no
i don't no you don't see it you gotta
load it up yeah give him another start
you don't leave here until four in the
morning i'm gonna treat you like an
orchid see you leave that stop
put that put it in your mouth put that
back no let's go one at a time
you got to digest it in your [ __ ] now
you got to you got to put it in your
butthole this is what i've been
suspecting
since [ __ ] day one camera stealing
stars you will internally take it
through [ __ ] he got those chocolates
and he put him in the fake bag
no they're not got those what do you
call those kitkats
and he put him in the process
and he made a tape and i could tell
he wasn't eating real marijuana because
he was eating the chocolate and smiling
eat that [ __ ] starly don't make me go
over there and stab you in the hot pot
ah come on man let's go everybody ate
nine tonight
i ate ten you gotta eat nine tonight you
know you're ten yes i did
every time it's two minutes i ate eight
plus two what's that in your my [ __ ]
country
okay
please stop complying i'm right in front
of you go back to the video today go
back to the video tape tonight i have a
paper towel and you'll count eight of
them what happened eat the star first
and i'll give you the paper towel did
you just is it on your pinky what's on
your pancake what's up
okay well just lick that you're a savage
you're you're a man eat that with the
star jesus yeah eat it with the star
cheese because we have no idea how high
i'm going it doesn't matter is it not a
high what's two you know high what's two
more hundred milligrams and look at your
finger gonna do it yet it's repeating
everything it's hard to believe you're
saying
you've been asking me if i'm okay
last week the kid called me when he left
danny because i was embarrassed how to
talk to lee like that yeah because this
is every week eat the goddamn start and
knock them off lee honestly you look
very alert yeah thank you i thought so
yeah like if you were in the exit role
of a plane they'd be like this guy's
definitely here this guy's the pilot
yeah if anything happens yeah this is
everybody this is everywhere we have
this yeah you mean [ __ ]
hand of mouth
let's go lee what the [ __ ] it takes so
long
there you go there you go do it big boy
big boy there you go there you go
you're like joey chestnut with the last
nathan's hot dog
two minute mark
are you
swallow the [ __ ] thing
[Laughter]
we gotta have a good time on the show
from time to time
i'm so proud of
thank
you
that [ __ ]
everyone saw that on tape too
[ __ ] you no you're the good one
i'm just testing you guys he's gonna
wipe the thc off his finger
we gotta eat another one before the
star's night yeah yeah it's the fourth
of july weekend celebration
if you're gonna make a comeback you're
gonna make a comeback what else is going
on you said you did a document
uh did a documentary i just wrapped it
up you know we have a little bit more
work to do obviously but uh the bones of
it are done yeah amazing jonathan yeah
amazing jonathan uh
you know he's a staple in vegas comedy
central back in the 90s
so he was recently diagnosed with
cardiomyopathy and
basically like half his heart
is uh he's dead and he was told three
three and a half four years ago that he
had a year to live
so he retired and then he made a return
to the stage and i was like somebody
should document that and i just thought
well [ __ ] it i'll just go document it so
i documented it and then
as most documentaries spiral and take a
life of their own it started off as one
thing and became something totally kind
of different and heartwarming and sweet
so
it you know we're hoping fingers crossed
it'll come out within the next year year
and a half yeah so he's he's he's an
amazing story he's a great guy
he's [ __ ] hilarious like truly truly
[ __ ] hilarious and i'm glad that
we're
you know we're creating a vehicle for
another generation to get
get used to him again
and see his talent and appreciate him
you okay lee no i love it i thought it
was hysterical when i was a kid what are
you doing because i grew up i grew up in
the 90s and i used to love all those
rick mills comedy central yeah yeah yeah
yeah all those oh it's so funny the
windmill at the end yeah yeah and and
uh
i know joey i mean i i like magic it's
it's cool i was i was a fan of his i
mean
not like a die hard but it was it was
cool
yeah the documentary is pretty i'm uh i
didn't know he was sick
[Laughter]
something in there made sense
it's funny i saw him once in seattle
he's looking at me like like he's like
i'm a prosecutor and he's like did i say
the right thing
he's not [ __ ] done this poor bastard
he don't know it yet he knows i love him
yeah
he's over here [ __ ] rocking it every
night this week he's got to buy he's got
the rest of the week oh
he doesn't even have to train but lee
when we make a comeback on sunday we're
hitting this [ __ ] with ten bungs
we're going on a ten bunk there so if i
was you i'd take that medium bong home
but
start training
and practice over the weekend
you know i just thought about a hot dog
burp a good new york city sabret dog
when you burp that [ __ ] with
onions and mustard oh
after you have a can of coke you know
that you've burped but when you have
that burp you're like i could have
another one now oh [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
almost like a it's almost like you
missed living in new york at all
i miss like i miss the fun of like going
from set to set and like that high of
going from club to club and reading the
room and seeing all your friends i miss
that part
but now with the wife and kids it's like
i can never see myself living in new
york city again it's just i don't i like
having a yard how old do you now stay
right 42 you're still going on the road
four weeks a month yeah
you don't take no weeks off
i take uh probably four or five weeks
off a year that's kind of yeah i i just
grind
no no no you know sporadically but i'm
grinding you know it's you know what
other choice do i have that's that's the
it's the career i've pursued the last 20
years of my life
and yeah i mean definitely it's gotten
harder as i've gotten older especially
the last year or two it's ba it's become
a lot more difficult because
i have a five-year-old and almost a
two-year-old so it's tough to leave the
kids but you got to keep the lights on
you know but i think the trap a lot of
comics fall into is not staying relevant
not writing not creating not
creating different opportunities even
for yourself i've never in a million
years thought i'd be directing a a
documentary film that we're submitting
to all the festivals i've never had a
million years would i ever
but doing it and
it's just another experience and uh it's
another creative outlet so i i really
appreciate it maybe it'll lead to other
things but at the end of the day if
that's if this doc is the only doc i
ever did or only film i ever did i'd be
so proud of it because i really am i'm
really proud of the relationship we
conveyed in it and i showed it to
jonathan
he got up he said it's great i love it
and he left the room i think maybe to
think about what he'd just seen but uh
but
hearing his
praise of the film
meant more to me than
i could never make a dime off of the
film and i'd be happy knowing that he
appreciated and loved what he's what
he's how long is the film
uh 90 minutes
can't cover the whole tour or just just
come back
it's hard to explain but yeah a little
bit every shame attack is still open
from
she
is
opening for him years ago yeah i don't
think so because like she was open from
she was his assistant yeah who the [ __ ]
knows what happened yeah
but it's uh it's damn good i think it's
something that
even most jaded comedians
could take a look at and go that's
[ __ ] good
because it's you know i think when you
do those things it's like what would i
want to see and this is that's the
reason i did it it's like i'd want to
see that film
and i was like well i'll [ __ ] go do
it i'll see if i can do it and i think
we i think we pulled it off
good for you man yeah it's always good
to do different things to keep you
fresh and calm you off yeah
i look at comics sometimes i have a new
documentary called hot dog burp yeah
that's a good one too it's funny how
over the years you pay attention to your
career yeah
but you also keep your eyes on other
people and since i've been here 20 years
i've watched the rise they're full and
how they've done it how montreal they
went and got a deal once the deal fell
through they were lost
and it's so weird how uh
the thing about being a comic is that
you go through the ups and downs like
and i always used i used it the other
night
margaret show tom rhodes
and greg geraldo they were scapegoats of
the 90s after tim allen's success in
roseanne
the networks went looking for the next
comic superstar yep they tried with a
korean american they tried the spanish
kid and they tried with uh whatever he
was gregoraldo
and all three of them got yanked off the
[ __ ] air you know tom rhodes yeah
and i always think about those guys
how they were all like two seasons three
seasons
how i would have felt yeah you know
and me at the time at that time when i
moved here i would have quit coming
because that's the type of [ __ ] i am
yeah
now i know that
you don't quit comedy it's your
oh yeah bread and butter
like people who have come and gone since
i've been here steeper and then you sit
there and go jesus christ
i had uh you know
deep conversations about comedy with
them yeah how the [ __ ] did they just
quit yeah
how the [ __ ] we just had a great
conversation about future and um those
guys weren't really real you know they
didn't like it when the waters got murky
yeah water's got murky for years here
yeah yeah nothing stays adrift for long
in this career no you have three good
months then you have a month of murky
waters
then you have two good months then you
have another month of murky waters lee
do you see why that bug keeps attacking
you and it keeps coming back cause you
reek and you keep eating that hummus
it attracts those [ __ ] bugs
maybe it's the
stars no i see if you eat more stars the
thc stinks them away so that's what well
there it is on the floor he's going your
way lee
kill him come that way
kill him dead he's going your way
every night we get attacked by a bug and
it's always him last week there was a
bee with wrestlers maybe did you bring
him in man are you i don't know listen
let's pretend i bring them in
why do they go to you because you've
trained them to my sense you know you
might think to my senses you have
hollywood friends i don't know if you
have bug friends leave me the [ __ ] alone
close people yeah i hang out with
somebody from a e you [ __ ] sucker
and when does this film premiere what do
you think i don't know we're going to uh
edit it right now
yeah tail end of editing
um yeah and then we'll submit it uh over
there
i think by october is when you have to
submit it so it'll be you know the edit
sound color all that'll be done by then
uh and then we'll submit it we'll see
what happens but i i like our chances i
think it's i think it's you know i know
of course
you know when you do it you think oh
yeah it's [ __ ] great but i really
truly believe it's
it's something i'll be uh i'm proud of
it now i'll be proud of it when people
get get the opportunity to see it that's
for sure listen man the thing is taking
chances yeah that's the most important
thing in life if you don't take chances
and you just protect the little that you
have
what are you gonna grow from it you're
not gonna [ __ ] grow from it at all
yeah this is a growth process
this is
if you came to me 20 years ago and told
me this i would have [ __ ] told you to
go [ __ ] yourself
now i'm the first one that tells comics
yeah
this is not a [ __ ] race man this is
oh it's a marathon totally yeah and
you're gonna see how many people drop
out of this right yeah
and next thing you know there you are
yeah why because you're funny and
everybody know because you got less than
everybody yeah you're not funny
everybody you just outlast everybody you
took the number right the deli yeah you
know you take that number at 63. yeah
it's a long wait yeah but it's a long
way to the top of rock and roll
that deli sign could either go quick
yeah or you could go [ __ ] slow it's
up to you if you know how to cut and
maneuver listen i'm just gonna call it
back on the potato salad do you mind if
i go in front of you
that's the game here the gaming we're
still here 20 years yeah i sit here and
scream what do you think i wake up in
the morning jump up and down
i wake up every morning on my hands and
knees and i go god
who's better than you you bad
[ __ ] i've been here 20 years and
nobody found that yet i'm just a sack of
[ __ ] yeah nobody knows i'm not funny i
just [ __ ] jump up and down and yell
yeah you know there should be so many
comics that you'll wake up every morning
and get hands on their heels and go
lord please thank you for giving me
another day for not letting them know
i'm a [ __ ] sex you know what i'm
saying so i get up every morning i think
you know
and even yeah i know i was driving to
the comedy store on a sunday night and i
got to be honest as i was parking the
car i go what the [ __ ] possessed me
to call the store on a sunday night who
the [ __ ] am i i got a two-year-old
four-year-old yeah and as i'm backing on
my driveway i go joey
54.
you're still doing spots at the comedy
store this sunday night at 10 45.
how lucky are you yeah i think back to
holt's been going you don't want your
spot
don't do it yeah put the sign outside
and tell people i have the 10 45 spot
who wants to do it see how many people
sign up for it yeah you really think
about it that way how fortunate i am so
yeah
once an elite club yeah when i saw the
end i was going saturday and i was on
long island you were at the store
and they took a picture you and they put
it on twitter and i'm like well he's
home you know it's good though yeah you
got it bro you got to go down there yeah
even uh the week off i still went to the
store i was like i gotta you gotta go
down there nobody says you gotta go down
four nights and yeah go run over to jay
davies and join and do eight spots and
do the main room in the original room
yeah and do the belly room listen the
kids going to bed at nine eight i gotta
read a book though yeah yeah i can't
make your [ __ ] belly room show at
eight o'clock all right so knock that
[ __ ] off you want me down there at 10
15. i'll be down there at 10 15. what's
bothering you lee what do you got on
your elbow now what is it money more goo
no but don't forget about tony bennett
well put it on don't you forget about it
it's a beautiful monday
26th of june can't get no better than
this
with your producer
huh
that's my producer wiping
thc google office elbow that's why can
you wait till you get home [ __ ]
no that's like that that's 12 000 years
in prison that's you
what's that [ __ ] bed bug that's
following you bites in the leg [ __ ]
sucker
you sent me on that
holy hondo
you got a lot of work coming up but
you're sitting tight for a few weeks
no i'm hitting the road and i just
started writing
a new hour so i i got like 15 minutes
what a [ __ ] night man yeah i got a 45
to go first 15 to go what a [ __ ]
nightmare yeah and then little by little
you start connecting the dots and you
pick up a quick 20. yeah you're like all
right i'm halfway [ __ ] there i'm
cooking with gas
but then you put the whole hour together
and you're like wait a second i'm doing
my hour every [ __ ] night for the last
eight weeks polishing it up all these
people are seeing it once they see it
again i'm [ __ ] up let me write another
half hour to throw them off in here so i
don't have the same thing
then the week that you tape it you book
thursday and you do a show a warm-up
show just to get your [ __ ] tight maybe
two on friday saturday
that's a ticket how i would do it next
time to be [ __ ] loose and yeah
but i'd work on an hour and a half so
they wouldn't see the whole thing when
they watched especially they go i saw
this i just saw this in minneapolis i
just saw this right that's why i never
could figure out
that's why i can't
just i i i gotta break it up i can only
go out twice a month yeah the rest of it
kills me between the podcast and my wife
i'm a little on the older side dog that
long six hour flight kills me for two
days yeah
yeah look you know
there's times where i'm exhausted and i
i'm like
it's not not wanting to perform because
i love performing it's the flight it's
getting on a plane it's going to the
airport it's the pickup it's doing
morning press all that [ __ ] i [ __ ]
can't stand the gig itself is [ __ ]
brilliant i love the gig i love going up
and the minute i go on stage and i'm
introduced and you see those people and
they're clapping it's like this is why i
got on a plane so i mean it
it works but
it's gotten tougher as i've gotten older
for sure when i was younger was like the
[ __ ] principal no when i was younger
i would leave in september come back in
january i was one of those savages and
send clothes home yeah every week i'd
stop at a [ __ ] walmart buy a new one
these socks
if it didn't have holes in that put in
the box and send it home yeah right to
josh wolf's house i get back and have
four boxes after four months yeah anyway
you went you picked up cheap tour
clothes yeah it's gonna [ __ ] up anyway
you're gonna lose at the airport it's
gonna get wet in those days i was flying
frontier and the beer airlines you know
now you fly the ia airlines yeah but for
a while you fly the bee airlines i mean
you getting your luggage is wet jack i
think nobody giving you if it's there if
it's there yeah frontier always it's
always the other one there was like four
of them frontier spirit spirit saw oh
you'll lose your luggage for sure
your luggage is an egg why is it you
complain on spirit they're like be lucky
you got a seat yeah
that's the one where you got to pay as
you get on right you pay for the seat
and then you pay for all the all
everything oh you want a fruit basket
that's an extra 18 oh you want a blanket
yeah oh no they go they go as far as
like a carry-on
they don't there's nothing for free you
you you if you want to be on going for
free you have to walk out and buy
yourself no backpack no nothing i'm
surprised they don't make you break a
dollar so you got to put a quarter in
those things to use a toilet you know
like in new york sometimes you got to
get get changed to go take a piss
the worst yeah spirit i wouldn't be
surprised if they're six months away
from that [ __ ] how crazy is that
we used to pay a quarter to take a piss
yeah
or a nickel it was like a nickel or a
dime
then we figured out you could put slugs
in there
once me and my friends could get slugs
in new york city game over [ __ ] how
much does slugs cost
10 cents on a dollar or something they
didn't give a [ __ ] it was all profit
some guy at some [ __ ] metal shop
would just cut circles yeah the shape of
nickels
and they'd buff them out maybe yeah
those things were sharper than
reach in your pocket for one of those
things you got four stitches
you had to [ __ ] do it slowly jack
you know after a while you just get
slugs for everything yeah figure out the
ones for the phone
it was such a corrupt new york when i
was growing up yeah when i left new york
in 85 it was still
so [ __ ] everything was so attainable
and i got to be honest with you i didn't
like it
how easy it was didn't like it man yeah
it was very scary easy
you go into the city at four in the
morning and go to an apartment and
announce a blow or
give him 10 minutes i'll have a kilo
here yeah show him the cash take him
back to the car that kilo be here within
15 minutes
you want a weapon guy introduces you to
a nine millimeter it shot four people
hotter than [ __ ] 75 off the press yeah
i'll take it what else you got well my
friends across the neighborhood got a
[ __ ] tank
with a missile up in the bronx he's
looking for 20 g's cash right now you
know what i got 15 seven
in the car can i take it let me make a
call 15k right now i think the [ __ ]
you know new york was that attainable at
one time when i really saw
the guts in new york i was like wow yeah
this is not good for a guy like me yeah
you know because i know how to hustle
you come up to me go i need a dirty gun
i know i can get it for 75. give me 200.
right now 200 boom i just made a buck on
the call i didn't do no i just drove you
into the city yeah and gave you a gun
you know i wasn't thinking about who
you're going to shoot i'm not going to
shoot your mother in the [ __ ] head
now i feel terrible you know
no no but it's uh that's what i didn't
like how easy
accessible life was in the 80s yeah it's
very scary yeah to think that but it was
very true
quaaludes you know you could
prescriptions were easy
you know you fell we get unitary i mean
everything was so
such a robbery you know right i'll never
forget 1988
89
if you rented a dumpster yeah
the regular construction dumpsters
16 feet by eight feet those regular ones
yeah in colorado
a dumpster a day was 200 would pick up
that same dumpster in new jersey was
2200 jesus what
everything in new york
it at that time was just a [ __ ] crime
what they were doing and i know stories
that i feel bad about now
but then i was like jesus christ like
just jobs that people got no show jobs
like new york was just one big [ __ ]
scam when it was growing up
you know apa trucking was a great place
for a young man you got in high school
and you didn't have a job and you were
have [ __ ]
go jets jets jets those guys yeah we
think those guys are cheering for the
jets that go to the games and you see
them going go jets jets jets what do you
think the opportunities are for that
poor bastard yeah he goes to apa truck
and a guy like that
he gets 24 an hour right out of high
school yeah 16 hours a night five nights
a week do the [ __ ] man that dude's
buying a house in a year yeah cause he
lives with his mother
he drinks on fridays he watches the jets
yeah and he's a mule
and he'll be a mule for 10 years i'll
never miss a night of work yeah but to
get into the union you have to work
eight days
to shop steward's job is not is to make
sure they don't hire any uh
they don't let nobody work eight days in
two months right your job is to get the
eight days
so you got to pay somebody yeah
so you go there at eight o'clock you
stand online i'm just making an
imaginary situation up and it's like on
the waterfront they pick you
they pick lee they pick me it's because
i gave the guy a 50 bill yeah you know i
figured let me pay a hundred i get two
nights of work
you know in those days it was 18 bucks
16 hours and 18 bucks for two nights for
a guy like me yeah that's a score jack
yeah
and i had to pick up
volkswagen [ __ ] hoods
like i'll never forget carrying the hood
yeah of a volkswagen like you know
picking it up and going jesus christ
picking up engines
like your back goes after a while but if
you're a mule anyway
it's not a bad job though yeah
you could buy a long sherman's book when
i was growing up for 1500
1500 you could start shaping dog yeah
and that's a [ __ ] you get on with the
company
you don't work i mean my dad my friend's
dad my good friend timmy his dad i mean
the old days like if you worked you made
like a grand but if you didn't work you
got like 144 a day which
you know back then it's pretty [ __ ]
82. that's not a [ __ ] bad little
score yeah
you got a spot tonight or something no
my wife is uh
my wife's on my height so yeah i should
get going soon yeah let me give a shout
out here yeah good to see you steve
brown always good to see you i'm happy
about this movie thank you so much very
excited about your special thank you i
was also very excited about you know uh
just that you're out you're still
[ __ ] doing your thing
grinding that's that's all you can do
that's what we're doing right d in
colorado my girl meg
kanye six
kane
j bratorius
not rob g andre nebs
cynthia chen says
and burton macklin
i'm gonna be at the [ __ ] ice
house thursday night the 29th 8 30
working out with uncle joey 10 bucks
i got six topics we'll go over them like
family then the following week i'm at
the south point casino hidden in the
western in the hudson what is it called
the federal witness relocation plan at
the end of the strip yeah so make sure
you come to the south point 7 30 show
i'll have you out of there by nine and
go see rogan at 10 with tony hinchcliffe
who's better than your uncle joey where
you at next week tarzan
uh i'm at the hollywood improv friday
and then next week i go to dc draft
house and then i go off to montreal for
two and a half weeks for the just
[ __ ]
you're going to montreal like a soldier
ever all our canadian people get cassius
morris on it yeah to make a call and go
[ __ ] take the troops to go see you
we'll get my girl charlie then go see
you in munch good for you man thanks bud
that's what you're supposed to be doing
all right go ahead we're going to do
like 15 minutes after you got to go i'm
happy i love you boys thank you so much
go to the hockey game tonight
oh my god
okay take care buddy love you joey go
through here
thank you so much bud
okay yeah
okay all right thank you brother you got
it guys
what's up lisa yet it's [ __ ] monday
what do you got planned for the rest of
the week i'm gonna go away with the
family i'm very excited i'm gonna hook
up with my daughter's godfather you know
i want her to have a relationship with
the godfather he's bringing his daughter
so i'm taking a flight tomorrow morning
and uh we're gonna hook up for two days
so i'll be back in town thursday night
for the show she is a princess of
burbank airport who
mercy well this is her first time flying
out of that she's never flown out of do
you think she'll like it i think that'll
be fun i think it'd be really cool to
come out on the tarmac as a little kid
no i don't [ __ ] know but i'm excited
that i'm taking her away
for two days with my wife just to uh
you know i got to do something different
i and i trust me
i was against it because you know me i
have to go to jiu jitsu and stick to it
but
i'm gonna i'm gonna do some drill class
tomorrow at 10 30.
i'll be home and uh the car pick me up
and i'll get the [ __ ] out of there later
in the afternoon so
it's good for me because guys let me
tell you something
i'm the laziest sack of [ __ ]
when it comes to doing stuff with my
family of that level like i hate [ __ ]
vacations
anybody who knows me knows i'm not fond
of vacations but
i'm not doing it for me it's not about
me it's about this little girl
and her relationship with her godfather
you know
i was talking to somebody today and
nobody really knows
like if you're a catholic that's one
thing but
i think in today's catholicism world
the godfather godmother situation is
taken very lightly
we're in my world it was taken very
seriously i was very very very very
fortunate
after my father died that my godfather
would pick me up every [ __ ] saturday
and take me to a movie
take me to get a cheeseburger
it was just a really really good uh
environment for it was he he was the man
i needed you know
in the cuban world when you're a
godparent to somebody
and the parent or parents die you're the
first one on the scene
that's just an unwritten rule and let me
tell you something guys he stuck by it
and like i said i told the story before
we were tight till all through my
grammar school
but i didn't really know at the time
what he did and he was in miami half the
time
sometimes he was doing time who the [ __ ]
knew what he was doing
and when my mother died he showed up and
we kept in touch
and then one day i called his number and
it was disconnected and i was very upset
you know with everything else i had
going on in my life at 16 and 17 i
forgot all about
and i i saw him in 84 and he befriended
me and we were friends again and uh
i could lie to you and tell you that
from the time of my befriend to him it
was to see what i could get out of him
as a godfather my job was to make him
feel guilty so he would i could get cash
out of him or whatever
and he opted to give me coke to sell you
know that was his way of helping me and
i appreciate it now but i think about it
now they think about the movement and
how on
[ __ ] godfather-ish it was i ended up
not paying him he ended up threatening
me looking for me
this went on for years he moved to south
florida or whatever
people say when they see him he's old
and he still says [ __ ] about me like
that's how pissed
and he's not mad at me i broke his
[ __ ] heart you know so
i've never been a godfather to anybody
you know i don't think i'm [ __ ]
worried to be some child's godfather but
when i asked my friend to be mercy's
godfather i asked him because he's older
uh
i've known him for 40 [ __ ] years and
he's got a daughter too and i know the
type of dude he is
he steps up to the plate so i'm really
fortunate that uh
he called me last week and said i'm
going to san francisco next week and i'm
going to drive down and so i said you
know call me when you get in when you
get a little closer
i'll [ __ ] meet you somewhere you know
so
he's driving right now we're gonna hook
up
and uh we're gonna hit the coast and do
a few things and
take my daughter and his daughter to a
few little things and uh
i'll be back thursday and she gets to
spend time with a godfather a god sister
and i get to take my wife away and
everybody's happy sounds wonderful and i
get to spend time with the cats yeah
well everybody want to stay in over two
nights so you could come over in the
morning and say hello and talk to juan
in spanish
see what's going on i'm gonna leave one
over there that gives me
peace of mind because that's my biggest
fear is them being alone at night okay
they don't like being alone i've been
around those cats for so long i'll
probably go over at least and say hello
to harry i haven't seen him it's crazy
how
i've gotten
i never thought
this would possibly happen but i've
gotten even tighter with your cats
like demi and harry are just two
saints of [ __ ] cats
they really really are i'm very
fortunate i'm very fortunate to have all
my [ __ ] cats but those two
[ __ ] we have a bond now like
today i was watching something the news
and debbie sat next to me
and i rubbed his belly and he grabbed my
hand and i rubbed his chest
and i rubbed under his chin and i
remember four years ago no five years
ago if i would do something like that
he'd get up and run away
now i just manhandle him you know what
i'm saying like there's a complete trust
there's a complete trust with me and
harry harry doesn't like to get picked
up and kissed no but i'll still pick him
up from time to time to give him a big
kiss on the face that's depressing to me
he seems like a lovely he won't he won't
hiss or nothing like that he just
doesn't like getting pissed up picked up
the girls
lulu loves love today i went up to lulu
and peddled and shimmy out at me
and evie always sits by the door so i
touch evie for good luck
and when i come home evie's in the same
spot and i touch her because she's
always there when i leave
and when i come back she's the reason
why i come back so i always touch a
little head and give her a kiss
and tell her i love it's just amazing
how close you get with your [ __ ]
animals man
so i'm really happy that i kept them and
uh
they've been by interesting weekend you
know long island was [ __ ] phenomenal
four shows they weren't packed shows but
they were great audiences
i want to congratulate governors because
they've had a movie shoot there called
the comedian
and they've had crashing shoot there in
the next in the last year
they've really done a great job as a
comedy club you know
[ __ ] 15 years ago governors was a
hello oh really oh i remember going
there in 98 i ran the [ __ ] out of there
that was a [ __ ] hellhole jack
so to see what this owner has done with
it to see how nice the place is
my applause it was a great weekend
like i said i'm home this weekend i have
the ice house thursday night
and then next weekend we're at the south
point and the weekend after that we're
in st louis
and the weekend after that july 29th
we got the [ __ ] borgata in new
jersey
and that's how it is lee that's the way
it's [ __ ] cracking for the next
couple weeks
i got my jiu jitsu i got my health
and that's it my brother let me read
these ads and we'll get you the [ __ ] out
of here
i appreciate you people listening to the
podcast and supporting us
in the high level that you have been
this is a good show you know why because
i really love you [ __ ] and i
know lee loves you [ __ ] of
course without you [ __ ] we
would both be doing something we
wouldn't want to be doing
we would be sitting up all night and she
knows this [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh
editing or whatever the [ __ ] it is but
you know what
this podcast is brought to you by quip
my wife and i got equipped and we love
it it is just tremendous it's easy the
best thing about it's got the little
timer brother and you can put it on
there it'll brush your teeth nice it
doesn't rip apart your gums but here's
something to chew on many recent studies
suggest that having good oral health
impacts your overall health which it
does
it affects your heart yet most of us
don't brush our teeth properly you know
what i'm a nasty [ __ ] but i've
always brushed my teeth you can start
with brushing better today
i'll tell you why including quip
introducing quip the new company that's
refreshing the way people brush their
twit their teeth
[ __ ] is an electric toothbrush that
packs premium vibration and a timer
feature into an ultra slim design
that's half the cost of bulkier brushes
it's basically like apple designed the
toothbrush but without the big price tag
you have to see it and brush with it
yourself you can even subscribe to
receive new brush heads on the dentist
recommended three-month plan for just
five dollars including free shipping
quip is backed by the leading dentist
and was named as one of the time
magazine's best inventions of
2016. they won the 2016
gq grooming award and made it on oprah's
new 2017 old list quip starts at 25
right now go to quip.com joey to get
your first refill pack
free with the quip electronic toothbrush
let me tell you something this is the
way to go it's refreshing the way people
brush their teeth
that's your first refill pack free at
quip.com
joey again g-e-t
q-u-i-p
dot-com
slash joey how's that for you number two
you know me people
but i don't like having something if i
don't like it
my favorite items in the world is what
i'm about to tell you right now and it's
me on these i love them i love how
comfortable they are and you can ask my
friends sometimes i wear a white ghee
and i wear color for me undies and i'll
go jerry what type of underwear has you
got on even my little daughter says
daddy's got panties on but i don't care
i love me undies there's a reason i've
been telling you about me on these for
months now they're simply the softest
most comfortable underwear you'll ever
wear once you try them you won't want to
wear anything else trust me unless
you're naked
or you're in a swimsuit
every other second of your life there's
me undies
every pair of me undies is sustainably
sourced and made from micro modal a
fabric that's three times softer than
cotton not that when you sweat you don't
sweat it retains the coolness all day
with this material if you're used to
buying packs of uncomfortable boring
underwear
that only in white they only come in
white gray black a tan
me undies will change everything because
my undies comes in all kinds of colors
and patterns and they release a new
limited edition pattern each month
that's always a seller this month it's
rainbow confetti print called celebrate
try me on these today
go get the celebrate pattern before
they're all gone at the undies.com
joey and you'll save 20 off your first
order you know why because i love you
and i take care of my family you have to
feel for yourself to see why me undies
has sold over 5 million pairs to date
and if you don't love your first premier
undies
they're free
get 20 off your first pair plus free
shipping at meundies.com joey right now
listen
you know me these are the underwears to
wear right now they're comfortable
they're cool they're easy to put on they
come right through your door you can't
beat it so go to meundies.com
joey again
meundies.com
joey so now you got a great pair of
underwear but you take them off and your
[ __ ] smells like the 10 dead billy
goats what are you going to do
guess what but days are back [ __ ]
happy
hellotushy.com is going to rock your
world what's hello tushie joey it's a
portable bidet that you attach right to
your toilet and every time you poop or
you don't pull but your balls are stinky
you sit on it you put the water on bing
bang boom and your ass is tip top mango
lee am i [ __ ]
no he's not bullshitting you and
even someone like me who can't build
anything
installed in under 30 minutes so it's
pretty great so there you have it it's
the most comfortable bidet out there
it's tremendous comes with a 90-day
guarantee listen
why should you get asked rod it's the
summer the humidity gets in there and
then they'll eat y'all from the inside
out you don't need that get a portable
bidet go to hellotushy.com right now
what is it lee go to hell
and there you go you get 10 off okay and
that's the way the party starts why
should you walk around with the
stinkiest [ __ ] in town don't you just
you ever sit on the train and you smell
your own [ __ ] that's when you know
you got problems right there that's
where hellotushy.com comes in the best
portable bidet out there in the market
90-day money-back guarantee it's the one
i use at least i at use and you're going
to be so [ __ ] happy with it you're
not going to know what the [ __ ] to do
you're going to get off facebook you're
gonna quit all this [ __ ] and you're
gonna sit in the toilet roll [ __ ]
joints and wait for the pizza delivery
man how you should that's how good hello
she is so again lee where do they go
hellotushy.com
church there you have it one more time
hellotushy.com
church one more time for quip and one
more time for me undies my most favorite
underwear in the world i'll see you guys
wednesday night stay black i love you
thursday night thursday night whatever
guys at the ice house but we'll see you
there wednesday morning and i'll see you
thursday night at the [ __ ] ice
house
8 30 p.m working out with uncle joey and
the following week at the south point
casino and the following week at the
[ __ ] saint louis helium [ __ ]
so get your [ __ ] together and then july
29th the boy gotta end this [ __ ]
philadelphia get your [ __ ] together
there's not a lot of tickets left stay
black uncle joey loves you
[Music]
hello
yes
yes
let's get started
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you